I think the only time I would ever wear
this getup is if my Halloween costume
was I'm a stone or til this went in from
Doctor Strange today we are trying on
Asian Halloween costumes
I am half Japanese Chinese American
Korean I'm Indian American the first
thing I think about with an Asian outfit
is just misrepresentation sumo wrestler
comes to mind probably dancing you know
chips tea heavy quotes maybe like a sexy
geisha should cost you that's like what
people often think Asian people look
like in America so my expectations are
pretty low oh my god it says Emperor's
lady looks like a cross between like a
kimono and a yukata covered in like
Kanji symbols oh man like it looks like
a shitty tattoo artist designing this
dragon kind of just looks like a like a
like a restaurant waitress I can't quite
tell like if this supposed to be like
Chinese Korean Japanese a bollywood
beauty costume fabric Bingle's
definitely not a thing I don't know it
could have been better but really it
shouldn't have been made at all it
definitely leaves like my entire leg
exposed because the slit goes like all
the way up to oh like my crotch this is
look at this like if I weren't wearing
pants it's just like right butt cheek it
really is like quite bathrobe II
literally doesn't look like anything you
would ever find in like history one
thing I am glad is like there's no like
Chinese Japanese Korean letters or
characters anywhere this is the only
time in my life I think I'll ever be
able to say that like I'm covered in
like words this whole thing is like a
crude approximation of of what Indian
women
and Indian people look like it's not not
very modest they also just feel like I'm
like in like a bad twenties movie and
I'm going to like serve someone tea I'm
not even not religious and I feel like I
need to go to the temple and like
cleanse myself these capitalist sins
imagine it's roll up like this trigger
tree when people decide that the
Halloween costume that they want to do
is Asian person I don't think that's
like the best or most inspiring idea for
a costume the culture of the kimono is
still alive it's still a article of
clothing that they wear today
we don't like walk around in this it's
like a traditional where there's value
to it there's history to it I feel like
that's often overlooked it does just
make me feel to an extent misunderstood
culturally it's kind of a slap in the
face to Asian people if you decide that
like it's suddenly cool to wear their
clothing when for the longest time it
wasn't cool for them to wear it
themselves makes you think about all
those times when I was a kid where I
felt ashamed and felt like I needed to
hide what I was wearing that identified
me as like a very Indian person because
if someone like me wore this out on the
streets no one's gonna think it's trendy
cool or like worldly they're gonna be
like go back to your country or like why
are you so foreign when I was growing up
I was told that I would make a really
good jazz man every Halloween it was
about my skin colour and not about which
Disney princess you know I reminded
people of by the way jasmine is not even
Indian definitely has to be like an
occasion in which like you're invited by
people of that culture to dress up in
their attire you can't just buy a
culture off Amazon Prime and claim to be
learning something from that we can be a
clown you can be a banana you can do
whatever you want but like nothing like
this that appropriate other's culture is
I feel really funny saying all this
while I'm wearing this
[Music]